when was it how long ago was it when big
hero six had its first germination the
seed sprouted how'd that happen from
from our standpoint I was about three
and a half years ago three and a half
years so you just kind of whip this
together that's a pretty good pace for
animation but um yeah I was finishing up
Winnie the Pooh and started talking to
John last week about what my next
project would be and he just he really
encourages us to follow our passions
mm-hmm because if we're not passionate
about it there's no way an audience is
gonna be passionate about it and it has
to come from the director has to be
where a filmmaker driven studio has to
come from the filmmaker and so I just
looked into my childhood what was I in
love with Disney Animation and Marvel
Comics and and we had just I think the
company just purchased Marvel not that
long before that and so I just pitched
that idea to Jon what if we took
something of Marvel's and brought it
over here and and just got inspired by
one of their ideas and then crafted
something here and he got super excited
and he's like go find something and so I
just did some research and came across
big hero six well let me just throw in
some done when did some exploration came
back with this idea and he pitched an
outline about three and a half years ago
that really emphasized that this was
really a story about loss and and he
told this really sort of a skeleton
pitch about a boy who loses his older
brother who's left with his older
brothers creation and and and this this
creation baymax was going to help him
sort of deal with the loss and recover
from the loss and and we were all so
moved by it by that pitch that everybody
was on board from that moment forward
mm-hmm and of course he was too young to
remember the loss of his parents but but
he's also at a loss there to to not
really have that traditional structure
yeah Tadashi really is his sort of
lifeline in the world yeah it's but it's
interesting because I think there's a
big thematic of family going through
here and obviously the brother
relationship is core to the actually the
baymax and Hiro relationship but it's
also the friends have friends transcend
into family as a big theme that we were
working here but you also kind of went
against and
film against the whole idea of superhero
movies the villain just kind of always
either dies or is really horribly comes
to a horrible end here
so you're he gets arrested but but
there's a morality here that's a typical
yeah yeah that come from well I mean in
a are you a softie at heart I'm a giant
softie at heart I kept trying to kill
him but let me know I mean ultimately
maybe this is going to deeper dive but
ultimately to me you know Callahan is
healed by hero and by heroes sacrifice
well and again the the the theme you
have going is from another angle his
daughter's still alive exactly exactly
and and what what you know what a choice
by hero to after all he's been through
to actually risk life and limb to go
after this guy's daughter and to me that
was the ultimate sort of aspect of what
makes a hero a hero and it echoes
obviously Tadashi the selfishness of
Tadashi running in that building and so
yeah ultimately I feel like hero
actually healed Callaghan so the thing
about animation that always amazes me is
that you basically have every every
second is a complete blank frame that
you have to create every single nine
million decisions piece you know you
don't were so tired I mean you didn't
have a little bit of influence by going
with Sanford you've even created your
own city you know and you and the design
of that and the and what that world was
and and all your heroes you were totally
redeveloping so what was the center idea
or the center of this movie that you
kept that kept you because to me you
made so many right choices how do you
keep centered so that you're not going
off on some other movie or with so many
collaborators how do you keep from
having somebody come in with a great
idea that really ends up being wrong
well first this one said you make a very
good point that an animation nothing is
you get nothing for free every crack in
the sidewalk everything that's in there
it's a choice that somebody made and
somebody had to design that thing and
light that thing and and so it's we're
always on a quest
180 and we're always looking for
spontaneity from our actors and and and
most we try to get it in the performance
as far as like the central thing the
thing that we kept going back to cuz
that's a big question for us in this
diagram we'll spend years working on the
movie coming up with iteration after
iteration and questioning our
assumptions and making the story better
and we're all we're always going back to
what's it really about what's it really
about and we knew it was a story about
loss that was central to to the the
concept and but we needed to say
something about that and and so we kept
circling around the idea that when you
lose somebody that you're close to
they're not really gone completely they
can live on through you and and affect
the choices that you make and and when
you when you when you accept that idea
it can be very cathartic and it was for
me in my in my life and that's one of
those things where you hear it a lot
when you lose somebody you hear that
sentiment and there's I think a danger
sometimes that that it can come off
trite but I think that one thing that is
that movies can be great at is reminding
people that that there is something to
these simple truths and they can be very
important and it can be very cathartic
and so that's something that we kept
circling around as we made this movie
and so we were yesterday 'king this
superhero film and with you know big
action scenes and comedy and all that
stuff wanted to be a really fun movie
but we knew if it didn't have a senator
wasn't about something it would all be
meaningless and I'll be you know just
disposable and so we kept going back to
that and you know we do a lot of
research in these and one of the big
aspects that we delved into was lost and
we actually talked to several
psychologists and social workers who who
deal primarily with teenage loss and it
was so informative and so helpful in
terms of building that emotional core
which is I'm so I'm so proud of that in
this film that it has this huge heart
yeah also just to go back to your
question to about like and you know how
do you stop somebody if they are not
stopped somebody but what do you do if
somebody comes in and has an idea we
never stop them and and I think our
process allows for that and it allows
for us to be wrong and and and test some
theories and try things out because you
know that during that three and a half
years we're constantly writing and
storyboarding the movie and presenting
it to our colleagues and
and John Lasseter and then we talk about
it afterwards so we're constantly
looking at things and trying out ideas
and again to try and get to that Center
what is the end and you own everything
down so it's about that thing and and
you know we we leave a lot of stuff on
our I guess kind of the cutting room
floor I mean it's basically storyboards
but uh there's a you know we try out a
lot of idea it's to get to that you know
to that home down version of the film I
think you're getting to something really
important as far as how we make movies
as directors were asked to have strong
convictions we have to know what the
movie is about we have to be able to
express that and we have to have strong
opinions at the same time we have to
foster a collaborative atmosphere where
people feel free volunteering their
points of view and disagreeing with us
and and we find that in that sort of in
that in that nest of conflicting
opinions comes great things and so we
always encourage that and and it's our
story room is very lively and it's full
of people who have the strength of their
convictions and and I think that as
directors we benefit from that and and
so I think that that speaks to sort of
how we make our films and and I think
why we've had so much success under John
Lasseter